>> PETER McDOUGAL IS
FEWER GAMES.
EVEN WITH THE COACHING
THE CROSSBAR.
AUTOPLAY.
A
MIX.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WILL MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS IF THEY RRY, I VASI
HE CAME UP HIGH.
THEY ARE PUSHING
SPEWING CLASSIC MANAGEMENT OF
THE PUCK BY THE LIGHTNING.
JOSEPH TRYING TO HUSTLE DOWN
THERE. BUT COULD YOU ABOUT POSI
KNOWING WHERE THE REBOUND CAN
COME OUT -- WHAT RONT.
SENT IN BY THE LIGHTNING.
THE N
DUCLAIR IS OFF TO AN EXCELLENT
START THIS SEASON.
BACK TOWARD THE CORNER.
SCREEN.
HERE IS THE COLLISION.
BARKOVNO PROBLEM --
>> ALL-TIME LEADER IN POINTS.RE
GET SOME PRESENCE -- ABLE TO
GET HIS STICIC
BOUNCES RIGHT BACK UP AND
CLEARED BY FLORIDA.
HARD, LONG RANGE IT GOES. IN TH
OFFENSIVE ZONE GETS YOU INTO
THE SCORING G
BOARDS THERE -- IT IS POUNDED
IN THERE BY WEEGAR.REBOUND.
BANKS OFF THE BOARDS.
IT IS SETTLED INTO THE POINT.
APPLY AGAIN. -- JUST WIDE.DOWNL
STAMKOS.
IT JUST DOESN'T GET THROUGH.
>> A REALLY GOOD READ.
SAVED THE DAY FOR BOTH
ADVENTURES.TO GO.TNING --
THE THIRD TIME IN THE LAST FOUR
GAMES THAT A GAME HAS GONE --
THEY LOST THEIR LAST TWO
>> HE WAS SMART.
HE WAS ONE ON
>> JUST OUTSTANDING GOALTENDING
VERHAEGHE -- WITH